bon il va se présenter ou pas tous et
c'est toi on espère bref ça je pense
qu'il va y aller oui moi je penses tu
vas y avait alors il va y aller on l'a
vu on vous a fait le week end eric
zemmour regardez franchement ça
annulaire partout là franchement très
sincère c'est un candidat tu vas voter
pour lui doit un nom pour benoît hamon
[Applaudissements]
c'est chez lui c'est la première fois
que tu vas voter non plus ouais
exactement 7 par dix ce qui me plaît
chez lui c'est son diagnostic c'est
qu'il a une façon de parler extrêmement
claire
et son départ attend notamment à
l'identité la sécurité d'ailleurs je
pense que ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
prouve encore par l'exemple ce qui
décrit en fait à longueur de temps ces
acteurs en france aujourd'hui on peut se
faire cracher dessus on peut se faire
insulter la rue il ya une insécurité moi
si j'ai 20 ans et je m'engage justement
c'est parce que je pense à l'avenir le
pays moi je respecte beaucoup les gens
le font avec zemmour à moi je pense
qu'on peut faire quelque chose il ya une
dynamite histoire et on n'a pas la rance
pour ce voyage tu veux 6 passes a vu
tous les candidats tu fais quoi dans la
vie ben là je j'ai fait du droit j'ai
travaillé à l'institut formation
politique et là je fais ça va quasiment
à plein temps adacore à trith a tout
arrêté du fait que ça va là en ce moment
et ça prend pas un gars toi même je fais
attention à toi
non mais moi j'ai envie de savoir quand
à 22 dont qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce
que c'est lui qui fait voter eric
zemmour est ce que cette part en voiture
et d'éléments non bah il n a jamais été
candidat donc
ce que moi je ne parle pas spécialement
que c'est ce qu'ils vont en boîte eric
zemmour ce qu'elle veut dire et sa jambe
au salon selma j'espère j'espère qu'ils
parlent encore été
pardonné parce qu'ils sont déconnectés
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi c'est l'insécurité juge qui
devait en premier c'est merci et à
l'insécurité et à l'identité il ya aussi
par le mauvais temps il ya aussi
industrialisation en france moi le moyen
tout m'a frappée par le co lead c'est on
est les français de la cinquième
puissance mondiale et on n'a pas été
fichu de produire des masques et ben moi
je voulais rester bon c'est un sujet
dont il parle lundi scalise à ce niveau
oui mais simplement de bruit mais là
c'est donc essayé par les jaunes et non
mais c'est vrai monsieur montebourg
monsieur montebourg dit des choses très
intéressant que sur la souveraineté de
la france mais je déconne on y voit
comment ils des conneries aux siens mais
si j'ai rien contre lui et moi
j'attendrais roche m'en fous il ya des
sujets comme ça aussi notamment sur sur
l'instruction par ce désastre national
foot c'est un beau discours ça fait
quelques années que le smic sur ces news
dans ses bouquins ouais on voit ses
déclas qui est intéressant qui a posé un
bon diagnostic tu la tiens rencontrer je
les rencontrais à nice le 18 août et que
ton monte et ça c'est bien beau mais il
ne sort pas toi n'essaie pas de te
donner des infos te dire voilà non non
tu n'es pas un petit vivant j'ai pas eu
de réaction des visages motion ça va
être des gens comme toi qui vont faire
sa campagne aussi au respect oui voilà
c'est ça il va vous êtes déroulé pour
eric zemmour est totalement mais c'est
ça si le sexe donc il le sait il le sait
donc il sait qu'il a des gens qui sont
autour de lui qui travaillent dans
l'ombre et qui attend là qu'une chose
c'est qu'il est qui donne logo nous la
rencontre et du tout à nice on fait ça
pour vous le voyez on a dit bon ben
voilà on est généreux avec tu l'avais tu
lui as tu l'as dit bao le dip qui on est
et on essaie ça les a remerciés pour
l'enthousiasmé qu'on avait pour ça pour
ses idées sa personne ça lui fait
plaisir mais je comprends bien sûr et et
était heureux dont tu l'as vu toi tu as
eu j'étais très content de le voir avec
les finances qui vous finance en fait
nous en fait c'est les années d'eric
zemmour si nous on n'a pas le choix
analyse yann
bridard
mais j'adorerais les brigades là bas
donc c'est l'association des amis des
risées mots qui nous finance et nous
après mois la honte et qui finance la
société générale en baisse et des
donateurs ses détracteurs pensaient
qu'ils font des dons moyen de 80 70
euros et ifs nantes marseille trois ans
la voilà que je serais déçu les morts je
serais déçu si eric zemmour se présente
pas ouais ouais bien sûr que tu crois
pas un instant tu sais qu'il va y aller
j'espère que j'aurai pas l'air d'un con
lui mais oui tu
parce qu'il ya une chance franchement si
les luttes ira voir des
qpc pour savoir attend juste derrière
paris match
c'est important sans rigoler alors on va
en reparler encore it off c'est hyper
intéressant ce qui est à nice la banc et
c'est vrai que vous avez vu un jeune
homme de 22 ans ces idées extrêmes et
font pas peur mais pour vaincre sa peur
à au moins 7 des extrêmes là je vous la
reine quand tu dis les oratoires sur les
prénoms temps en temps je voulais moi
j'ai moins envie que ces extrêmes et un
plateau ce matin et je regardais sur
twitter un peu ce qui se passait et là
je vois j'ai vu le programme du rpa dont
c'est chirac alain juppé donc ce n'est
pas non plus avec thom europe en fait ce
qu'ils disent c'est tellement study avec
zemmour vous pour vous si abdel et
samira font un enfant il faut qu'il
l'appelle jean pierre selon pas ou pas
et en fait c'est pas nous demander
comment il l'appelle il ya des prénoms
perdrix une multitude de prénom est
c'est fait partie des sujets pour moi la
simulation fait c'est pour moi
d'ailleurs fait d'armes je vais vous
dire il ya plein de pays où en fait on
est aussi obligé de prendre les prénoms
du pays en question et là plusieurs est
en fait pour moi c'est plutôt une offre
de la france est un agent qui viennent
la france
tatata conscience que pour plein de gens
quand on y joue et eric zemmour c'est
une connotation un peu l'impression que
tintin peu extrême voient l'accès à ces
ondes il est souvent encore à la droite
de marine le pen ouais sûr répond à ça
ben moi je vais prendre les choses de
très simple c'est que marine le pen
moi j'ai rien contre elle fut pas là
pour critiquer les autres y ait quelque
chose alors on est là pour critiquer
l'armée je suis là vraiment actuellement
non et le pen elle arrive pas faire
d'alliance avec les républicains les
républicains ne veulent pas s'allier
avec l'assemblée nationale eric zemmour
il est même pas encore candidat qu
etienne blanc à sénateurs approche de
laurent wauquiez appelle à le soutenir
julien aubert proposé tu fasses la
primaire bellamy ce matin a dit encore
sur public sénat thierry desmots
pourrait participer au congrès on a on à
monsieur ciotti qui a dit qu'en cas de
second tour marine emmanuel macron
pardon eric zemmour il voterait pour lui
mais encore une fois ces gens là on ne
peut pas leur faire le reproche d'être
d'extrême rock pour moi il n'est pas et
d'ailleurs en fait ce qu'on voit c'est
frey décrit d'insécurité en france est
en fait le jour où enfin que le
lendemain il a un problème c'est menacer
le nom il a parlé avec l'islam ah si
quand même pour moi il n'ya pas un
problème qui semble en bonne voie et
d'ailleurs il y fait le distinguo
extrèmement bas ils ont juste l'islam en
tant que tel ne peut pas forcément être
compatible avec la république et les
valeurs françaises c'est stylé mais
c'est par rapport aux lèvres bien ces
tomes sont déjà passés bien près may cry
4 8 ou les juifs prient avec des bas
c'est la même chose
toujours l'islam il parle pas tout ça
ça des heures il a parlé d'économie ne
vient pas et d'écologie et s'est opposée
au nucléaire face aux éoliennes des jean
luc mélenchon pas refuser les mois quand
j'ai vu le débat aussi bien non il parle
pas que de ça il est capable de
maîtriser beaucoup de sujets